[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN CHANDLER: Hey, guys.
Thanks for having me.
It's great to be with you.
My story is kind of interesting
because a couple of years
ago, some friends and I
decided to come over to Europe
and backpack around, but I was
the backpack, which obviously
caused some heads to turn.
And so people assumed that
my story started there,
and some people asked a lot
of questions about that.
But the funny thing
is it actually
started back before I was born.
My parents had two
children before me,
and their second
was named Connie.
And Connie, when she was about
the age where she should start
being able to walk on her own
and let go of the furniture,
she didn't.
She just kept holding on.
And when she did,
she would fall over.
And so my parents took
her to the doctor.
And that began several
months of testing.
And after a while of
testing, the doctors
came back with a diagnosis.
And the diagnosis was for
spinal muscular atrophy,
which essentially
means that the message
between her brain and her spinal
cord gets kind of jumbled up.
And so the message doesn't
get to her muscles properly,
and so her muscles
atrophy over time.
And so the doctors brought
my parents into a room,
and they were
explaining all this.
And they said, if you
have more children,
it will probably be
the same story again.
And this is already going to be
a difficult-enough life for you
and for your children, so we
would just suggest that you're
not have any more children.
My parents are very
good at loving people,
and they do it in two
very different ways.
My mom is a fighter.
She's the firecracker
of the family.
And my dad is the quiet,
behind-the-scenes one.
But my dad was the
one to speak up.
And in that room with
these well-meaning doctors,
he took my mom's hand
and he said, well,
if what you're telling us is
that the worst that can happen
is that we have another
child like Connie,
that's perfectly fine with us.
And about a year
later, I showed up.
And just as the doctors
said, it was the same story.
About the age where
I should start
letting go of the
furniture, well, I
was already falling down.
I never really got to that
stage of holding on to things.
And so life went on.
And I was diagnosed,
and my parents
decided that they had three
children, two of which
had this rare disease, and
that was fine with them,
and they were going to raise
us as normal as possible.
What that meant for them was
that we were going to have
extremely adventurous lives.
And so we grew up traveling, and
inviting people into our homes,
and going out into the world.
Although we were disabled,
we were completely a part
of the able-bodied community.
And it was just a really
wonderful experience
that I didn't fully understand
the power of at the time
until I grew up and
moved out on my own,
and realized that that
afforded me the ability
to interact with everyday life
just as a normal person, right?
As if any of us are normal.
And what that meant was, well,
I'm not living with my parents
now.
I have to have friends help me.
And that became my life, is
inviting people into my home,
and going out into the
world, and just melding
all that together to where I
had the help that I needed--
not inviting people in to
help, but inviting people in
to be a part of my
life, and realizing
that if we wanted to
experience this life together,
then this is how
it had to happen.
And so for the past
about 12 years,
I've been living on my own and
having friends take care of me.
I was doing the math recently.
Out of the, let's
say, 65 people that
have helped me over the past
15 years, I think one of them
might have been a
trained nurse, maybe two.
So most of them are musicians,
and that's a fun side note.
And almost all of them are
nerds, so that's also fun.
But yeah, it's my friends
and it's my community.
And because of that
community and these friends,
I get to live a normal life.
Not only that, but I
get to live a full life.
And so about three
years ago, some--
no, four years ago.
Wow, time flies, right?
About four years ago, some
of those friends and myself
decided, you know what?
We want to try and do something
without my wheelchair,
because we would go
and have potlucks
at each other's houses, and
some of those had stairs,
and I couldn't get
into the house.
And so we would just
leave my chair outside.
So we thought, well,
what if we actually
had an adventure,
where we intentionally
left my wheelchair behind?
And we decided, because we grew
up on Batman and Ninja Turtles,
that we would go into
the sewer system,
because that's not
handicapped accessible at all.
I found myself lying one night
on my friend's coffee table
with a metal frame underneath
me from a old hiking backpack.
And we took some hammocks
and wrapped them around me,
and came up with this
very makeshift backpack.
And we went into
the sewer system.
It was two friends, Tom and
Phillip, and then a couple
other guys helping out.
And for a whole
evening, we climbed
through pipes that were
probably too small and way
too filthy to be in.
We sloshed through
water up to our shins
and found out later on that
there were spiders that I
couldn't see, but they could.
Glad I didn't know that.
I almost got my nose ripped
off by concrete at one point.
It was, you know, your
average fun weekend
with some buddies from school.
And about a year later, we
started asking ourselves, well,
what else can we do?
If we can pull that off, if
we can survive, what's next?
So that's when we decided that
we would do the same thing,
but above ground, for
three weeks in Europe.
And we proceeded to come
up with a better backpack.
I thought that was a good idea,
because I wasn't going to live
for three weeks in a hammock.
That was going to
be uncomfortable.
So we came up with
a better backpack.
And Tom and Phillip, and then
a couple of other guys, Ben
and Robbie, and two
filmmakers came together
from all over the United States,
and we met up in Paris, France
in the summer of 2016.
And we had filmmakers to provide
proof that what we actually did
happened, because it was
so completely absurd to us.
So that's the back
story of a documentary
that we ended up making.
And we would like to show
it, if that's all right.
Does that sound good?
Cool.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I was born with a disease
called spinal muscular atrophy.
I'm supposed to sit
in a wheelchair,
take supplements, and
maybe work on a computer.
But instead, I let a bunch of
medically unqualified musicians
put me in a backpack and
carry me around the world.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
France to visit the home
of Django Reinhardt.
England to explore the
world of Kensington.
Ireland to brave the
Island of Skellig Michael.
And then plenty of wiggle
room in there for adventure
to find us, if she pleased.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And yeah, it was bound
to hurt, but I'm alive.
And I've seeing the world as we
all were meant to see it-- big,
and beautiful, and full of life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Nothing was out of reach.
There is no post-credit
scene, sorry.
Not this time.
But yeah, something
that I really
loved about the
whole experience was
that every turn that
we took, we never had
to worry about what
was accessible,
what was "wheelchair
friendly," quote unquote.
And that was all because of
the people that were with me,
and not only their physical
ability to carry me,
but also their creativity
and their willingness
to be creative with how
we would pull things off.
[CHUCKLES]
And so since then, we
came home from the trip.
And we had such a
response from people
asking, like I said in the
film about the backpack
and about traveling, where
did you get these friends,
you know?
[LAUGHTER]
I grow them in my backyard.
No.
But we wanted to give a
proper response to that.
And so we started a nonprofit
called We Carry Kevan.
And we'd been speaking,
sharing our story
for the past few years.
But we've also been working on
providing practical application
for people.
And so what that looks
like is we went back
to Deuter, the company that we
built the backpack with, and we
said, hey, what if we tweak this
to be more adjustable for more
needs and more people?
And so they've been
working with us on that.
And we're actually going to go
into production in the spring
to be able to provide
it on the market, which
is really exciting.
In the meantime, we've
been able to work
with families individually and
set them up with backpacks.
And the backpack
works for some people.
It doesn't work for others.
But the principle
behind it, which
is thinking outside the box,
and also people helping people
as true accessibility, is
really the key behind it all.
And so that's what
we're running with.
And so some people,
we work with them
on developing a
backpack for them.
Some people, we just meet
with, and talk with, and help
them come up with other ideas.
And then we're also introducing
people to each other.
There's a family
that we worked with.
We got them a backpack for
a trip out to the Rockies,
because the Rocky Mountains
are not handicapped accessible.
[CHUCKLES]
And this family went out there
with their six-year-old son,
who has cerebral palsy.
And his dad got to
carry him up onto peaks
that they would never otherwise
been able to experience
as a father and son.
And that was really special.
But when they came
home, I ran into the dad
one day at a coffee shop.
And he said, well,
we're actually
planning to go to New York
next year and do some camping,
but then go into the city.
Do you have anyone in mind
that we could meet up with
and maybe they could help carry?
And I had just heard from a
guy in New York City saying,
hey, if you ever come,
I'd love to help carry.
So we connected them and
said, well, I'm not coming,
but there's this other family.
Turns out the guy
works for the NYPD
and he had this whole
group of police officers
that wanted to help.
And so they got this
just awesome treatment
while they were in the city,
and got carried around by police
officers, which was pretty cool.
And they just got
back from that trip.
So that's just a microcosm look
at what we're doing on a larger
scale, and so connecting
people and providing
backpacks and other means of
accessibility outside the box.
Yeah, we also just got back from
China, which was really cool.
Again, coming back from Europe,
we thought, well, what's next?
What's the next big adventure?
So that's what we did.
We went to China
and spent some time
in some care centers that are
for orphans with disabilities
and provided some backpacks, but
also just hung out and played
with the kids, rolled
around on the floor, which
is what it's all about
at the end of the day.
Anyways, it's a
ongoing adventure.
It's a great life to live,
being able to do something
as crazy as this just
for ourselves for fun,
and then realizing how
we can give back now,
and that it's about a lot
more than just a couple
of guys having an
adventure around Europe.
We have a few minutes, if
there are any questions.
AUDIENCE: Just out of curiosity,
did you go with the same guys
to China?
KEVIN CHANDLER: So it was about
half the same group, yeah.
So on this trip, we had seven
of us, so four carriers,
two camera guys, and myself.
In China, we had three
carriers, and one camera guy,
and a translator, which
was very important.
[LAUGHTER]
But also with
that, we ended up--
because we had fewer carriers--
and it did, I would
say-- it ended up
proving to be a physically
more taxing trip,
because the Great
Wall, you know, period.
AUDIENCE: Is there a
documentary on that, too?
KEVIN CHANDLER: Not yet.
We're working on that.
But with that, because
we had fewer carriers,
we actually, as we met people
and interacted with people,
we invited them to carry as
well, which was kind of cool.
So the more, the merrier.
That's what we say.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
big adventures planned next?
KEVIN CHANDLER: Oh, well, I
mean we're here in Ireland.
[LAUGHTER]
No, we have a few ideas
of different places
we would like to go,
along the same lines.
Now, the big thing right now
is speaking and interacting
with families.
That's become our new adventure.
But as far as our next
big trip, it will probably
be a few years, but
we've talked about doing
a camping trip in New
Zealand, like actual tents
and that sort of thing.
But we've also talked
about going to India
and doing some exploring there.
And yeah, we have some
different ideas, so we'll see.
The big thing is
with each trip, we
look at what we
would like to do,
and then we see what doors
open, and then we go through.
We wanted to go to China.
We knew that at the
end of the Europe trip.
And it wasn't until
probably eight months later
that we just met the right
people and doors started
opening.
And so we decided
to actually go.
[CHUCKLES]
AUDIENCE: I have
one more question.
Based on your experience
and your family,
what would you
recommend to parents who
have small children with SMA?
Like some best practices.
Like, what do you think your
parents did really well?
KEVIN CHANDLER: Oh, man.
No, no, that's a big question.
You know, I've had a lot of
conversations with my parents
over the past couple
of years, because I've
met a lot more families
with disabilities.
And I've sat down
with my parents
and been like, what do
I say to these parents?
I'm the kid.
I'm not the parent.
And yeah, and my parents--
like I said at the
beginning, they
raised us as normal
as possible, which
took a lot more work for them.
But it was definitely more
worth it in the long run.
Also, realizing that
the people around you
aren't going to get
it fully, but that
doesn't mean that
they don't care
and that they won't help out.
And so inviting people into
your life, into your home,
is a big part of it.
It's going to be
uncomfortable, but it's also
going to be really rich
in the end for them
as well as for you.
So, yeah, yeah.
That's a little bit, I know.
Usually when I interact
with families or parents,
it's a few hours of really
getting into the meat of it,
but that's a bit.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Kevin, I have
a question for you.
So apologies for what happened
on the Irish motorway.
It gave us an insight, though,
into your mental strength
and your resilience.
KEVIN CHANDLER: My mental
strength and resilience.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk to us
a little bit about that and--
KEVIN CHANDLER: Sure.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
KEVIN CHANDLER: Yeah, you
know, I would say just
like the physical strength
that the guys provide to me,
I would say emotionally,
and mentally,
and spiritually, it's
the same in that we
have a joke that people are
like, oh, you're so brave.
I'm like, I have to be brave
for five seconds to say, sure,
why not?
And then I can be
yelling at them
the rest of the time,
what are you doing?
Why are we doing this?
And I'm on their back.
What am I supposed to do?
[LAUGHTER]
But I think that's the thing,
is having these friends
that not only carry you, but in
the morning when you're like,
I just don't feel like
getting out of this bed,
and they will really get you out
of the bed and keep you going.
And we have a lot
of conversations,
a lot of very open
conversations,
about how we're doing
emotionally with things.
And so we carry each
other through that.
I think that's pretty applicable
whether you have disability
or not.
We all need people in our lives
that can speak life into us
and speak truth into us.
And we can do the
same right back.
And so I would like
to say that I'm just
brilliant person
with this great,
was it constitution,
to forge the way.
But I could not do a
single thing on my own.
AUDIENCE: A question
on the community
that now is kind of a
[INAUDIBLE] building
since you started it,
and now a lot of people
would reach out to
you to ask for advice.
Are you planning, or maybe
it's already work in progress,
to build a proper
online community,
like CouchSurfing [INAUDIBLE]
or something that people can--
they know that it
exists, and they
can ask questions or reach out,
like a proper online community?
KEVIN CHANDLER: Yeah.
Oh, I don't want
to get in trouble,
because we're at Google.
[LAUGHTER]
But for me
personally, I've found
there are a lot of
support groups for parents
who have kids with
disabilities or individuals
with disabilities.
And there are a lot of
support groups online.
But what's really, I would
say, lacking in our culture
right now is people actually
having that face-to-face
and interacting.
And so we're definitely going
to provide information online
and provide a lot of resources.
But something that we're
working on right now
is developing weekend events
all over the world eventually.
We'll start with one.
But weekend events
that for now will
center around the backpack, but
hopefully will open up more.
And it will be families
with disabilities
and able-bodied people
who want to be involved,
but don't know how.
And so breaking down
those barriers--
an icebreaker dinner
party, you know?
You bring these friends
and these friends,
because you're the
mutual acquaintance.
Then you say, hey, you
guys would get along great,
and you put him in
a room together.
So we want to do that
everywhere, and just
introduce people, and
also promote the concept
that you might be coming
to help or you might
be coming because you
need help, but these
are all people involved.
And people need friends,
and people have feelings,
and people need
support on both sides.
And so hopefully speaking
some truth into that,
because it is easier to fall
into that categorizing yourself
of someone who needs help,
and so you're here to help me,
and I don't care
about your feelings,
or my needs are more important
than yours, or vise versa.
And if we can just build
relationships around friendship
first and foremost, then I
think a lot more gets done,
and it's a richer
experience for everyone.
So that's what we're
working on, yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER: It's a lovely
note to finish on.
Thank you very much, Kevan,
for being here today,
and to your team.
KEVIN CHANDLER: Yeah, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]